hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video das video
heute soll darum gehen dass eine
freundin von mir sagte hallo ich habe
ihr gesagt sie solle sich mal gedanken
darüber machen welche dinge ich oft tue
aber irgendwie unterschwellig sie soll
noch nicht sagen und ich reagiere zwar
sie darauf was für fakten sie
aufgeschrieben hat über mich die ich
glaube was meinen flug das kann nicht so
recht
das muss ich wünsche das ist ja was soll
ich dazu sagen es stimmt die schwache
private sage ich immer so dass ich wenn
ich irgendwie schlafengehen oder wenn
ich irgendwo andere sachen herumliegen
hab ich hatte dafür nicht einfach im
groben liegen ich habe auch nicht diesen
ort wo viele sagen okay zu frisch für
den kleiderschrank zu dreckig wie ein
kleiderschrank aber zu frisch also folgt
viele haben soll weil in ihrem zimmer so
ein stuhl einfach unterliegen dann zu
den sachen klamotten drauf das habe ich
halte die direkt an ihrem kleiderschrank
weil ich hasse das einfach in ordnung im
aufzuwachen
bild luca nicht luca ein solches wird es
noch dass du nicht still sitzen kann
wenn irgendetwas in peking liegt in der
küche steht so krass ist das jetzt das
so heftig ist also ich weiß nicht ich
faste unordnung merkt man dass
putzfimmel kann man ja aber ich bin
jetzt nicht einer der hier die ganze
durch wischt oder so ich weiß nicht wie
wir können so eine unordnung leben meine
schwester ist außer kandidat aber bei
mir ist einfach so wenn ich sehe da
liegt etwas könnte jetzt auch im schrank
seien dann macht mich das unruhig werden
nach den feiern zum lüften auge denn hin
und verlegen gespannt das geländer denkt
sie danach wieder still
es ist wirklich so ich hasse raucher und
ich hasse diese raucher gestank und
immer wenn man aber irgendwie im club
ist oder davor ständig meine freunde von
mir rauchen ja auch und das ist ja auch
völlig normal aber immer wenn ich dann
zu hause will man dann zu anderen sachen
rieche oder dann hose ausziehen ein
richter in der hose steht alles nach
rauch und ich bin okay bevor die
westschweiz ist jetzt nicht dreckig dann
stinkt einfach anhängig das einfach
irgendwo darüber und ich schwöre das
hilft mit tränen findest zwei liter
wasser hat in der nächsten zeit trotzdem
kater ich höre da sind nur welche
negative sachen im areal also ich sage
stimmt ich mache es immer so immer wenn
ich feiern war trinke ich danach so viel
wasser wie ich ihnen im haushalt oder so
viel okay sagt 36 liter flaschen rum
trinkt jetzt ohne je dabei ist es
eigentlich dass das beste gegen alkohol
einig so frische luft und viel wasser
treten ist und es ist jetzt nicht so
dass ich irgendwie jeden tag 14 flaschen
wodka reif aber wenn ich dann mal
wirklich feiern bin und erste spiel zu
hause und ich weiß am nächsten tag okay
wir müssen irgendwie früher aufstehen
dann existiert schon so 15 liter die
nachrichten miteinander für sie nicht
mehr schön wie du wird heißt immer also
fünfmal hintern
ander es ist aber bei mir wirklich so
ich weiß nicht ob ich irgendwie ich habe
das gefühl ich bin dauerhaft krank also
eigentlich bin ich nicht ich könnte
jetzt auch da wieder die nase putzen
weil ich glaube so viele menschen die
leben einfach damit dass die nase so ein
bisschen dass die halb so nicht ganz für
mich wenn dieses keine rechtfertigung
botschaft wer für meine angewohnheiten
aber ich weiss ich mache es ein wenig so
ich habe ihnen immer taschentücher dabei
herrlich weiter erkennung ist es ist
eine typisch luca nicht luca nicht luca
hat nicht in ruhe schlafen wenn du
denkst dass du nicht geschafft hättest
obwohl der video aufgenommen als es
geschnitten hat und noch trainieren was
aber schutze des 21 wenn du vorne weil
die ich einmal fort ich werde etwas dazu
sagen soll ich glaube jeder kennt wenn
man im bett liegt und ich denke auch ich
hab halt nichts geschafft aber bei mir
ist es dann halt einfach so dass ich
dann halt mir von die vorwürfe machen
und denke dass es irgendwie ein falscher
tag war zum beispiel letzten ist
irgendwie hast du das auf diese tage
nach dem feiern wenn man einfach erst um
2 uhr aus dem bett kommt und dann guckt
man ohne serien und macht man so gar
nicht zu das dann fix hält man nichts
geschafft
ich hatte das um produktiv zu sein wenn
du dir was du stellst immer viel zu viel
ich dachte echt ich jetzt sogar jeder
zweite sache stimmt nicht bisher hat
alles gestimmt wenn ich so darüber
nachdenke um das zu erklären zum
beispiel jetzt vor zwei tagen habe ich
so vollkommen spaghetti gemacht und dann
habe ich so zucchini dar eingepackt und
cherry tomate und hähnchen und
übungsturm so und ich weiß nicht
irgendwie bin ich jetzt voll darauf
kommen so selber sachen zu kochen und
ich denke mir dann so wenn ich das jetzt
einmal kochen und ich würde zwei tage
später wieder
muss ich diese gleiche sache das hat
irgendein tag stunde dauert noch mal
alles kochen deutschland über einmal
dafür zu viel macht mir zwei tage später
noch mal warm ist so logisch lieber
frisch kochen
ich habe so viel zeit hat jetzt ein
mensch steht nie auch wenn ein wecker
klingelt trickst mindestens fünfmal
schlummern anstatt ihn sofort auch auf
gestalten und weiter zu schlafen ihr
kennt doch mit sicher dieses bild von
mein geld mein wecker 36 36 35 06 uhr 36
das den fliege ich genau ich einen weg
entweder ich mache das so wie diesen
ganz viel meckern untereinander oder ich
stelle mir einen wecker auf 8 uhr
wenn ich ihnen im juni muss mache noch
schlummern dann klingelt um abdullah
abdullah antreten um 8 05 10 10 stichtag
auf der verbindung ein richtiger roman
sagt das war in letzter zeit vermehrt so
weil ich ja habe ich ein video gestern
gesagt den kompletten 17 mal bei meiner
familie war und jamaal die
internetleitung die ist so weiß nicht
gebrauchen ab gefühlt vier tage und das
ist dann halt oft dass ich meine videos
zu hause fertig geschnitten habe aber
danach wollte ich halten die mit
freunden
irgendwohin fahren und dann habe ich
gesagt okay bevor ich das jetzt zu hause
vier stunden warten bis das video online
ich einfach meinen datenvolumen rates in
die hoch wenn wir grad im auto sitzen
oder irgendwie weil sie nicht wild
wieder feld fahren oder so da hat man ja
auch eigentlich immer lte wenn ihr sie
diese ganzen prozesse wissen würde wie
ich was wie es dazu kommt dass ich ein
video hochladen würdet ihr mich nur noch
ausmachen weil ich glaube dass da
irgendwo in einem restaurant hof oder
irgendwo in unserer rolle heraus dass
aufgenommen nein das ist nicht leicht
kosten mindestens nach der toilette wenn
wir werden die wende
ja aber das ist völlig normal das ist
nicht typisch ist schwach ich schwöre
wenn ihr wisst ihr mist kacken und geht
aufs klo dann nehmt ihr doch euer handy
mit warum machst du denn jetzt fast
normal geworden ist das normal
du bist ob normal
ich nehme immer mein handy mit aus
klonen weil man da seine ruhe hat und
täglich mails und darauf zu lachen wir
machen weiter kommst immer mindestens
als verabredet ich schwöre eine sache
bisher positive ja es liegt also ich
glaube ich sagt freundin irgendwie immer
so jo einkommen das 14 uhr treffen dann
bin ich halt um 14.20 da finde ich
besser als er nicht sagen
15 uhr treffen weil dann bin ich halt
dann trifft man sich eine stunde später
aber endlich ja ich bin einfach immer
unpünktlich
beim shoppen geht und die vorgenommen
hat zum beispiel neue hose neue schuhe
zu kaufen dann kostet die reine neue
erke und neu sind oder das stimmt nicht
ganz
es ist nicht so dass ich sage ich geh
jetzt irgendwo hin und kaufen neue
schuhe und dann kaufe ich mir alles aber
keine schuhe sondern es ist schon so
dass ich wegen dass ich nachher nie
irgendwie bei sachen autos sieht schön
aus ist brauche ich es ich werde mich
hier raus oder als ich in berlin war
wirklich gehaltene rose und den t shirt
kaufen und was wir letztendlich gekauft
habe war mit lederjacke so als teuerstes
sage ich mal von den ganzen sachen und
das aber so dass ich nicht gesagt habe
otto lederer ist aber schön nehmen ich
möchte da habe ich wirklich schon zwei
monate davor immer im internet
beobachtet und habe mir gedacht ok
bestätigt die beständig die mir nicht
und das ist einfach so dass ich mir dann
kauft steht ihr das nicht meine verleich
tanken ein stellt jeden zweiten tag bei
amazon
die hälfte der richtige mix geboten was
amazon bestellt nur genannten technik
also ist auch die wahrheit
du hast wirklich nur die wahrheit
aufgeschrieben es stimmt eigentlich
alles bei amazon ist es halt so ich habe
von der uni dieses amazon prime und ich
weiß nicht ob es das so diese normalen
amazon leute die jetzt nicht träumen
haben auf die auf diese vorteile haben
aber ich kann halt bestellt ist es
eigentlich immer nahezu einen tag später
da und ich habe 30 tage zeit dann damit
ihm das machen und ich kann zum ersten
tor bestellt am ersten november
schädlich wieder zurück und kriegt das
geld zurücküberwiesen hab das zum
beispiel eine zeit lang bei
verschiedenen kameras natürlich mit der
sony alpha 7 es oben gespielt habe oder
mit einer 5 thema zwei aber irgendwie
macht das in letzter zeit legen wie bei
allen sachen also auch so bei kopfhörern
oder auch bei den sachen wo ich jetzt
dieses video letztes hochgeladen habe
die dümmsten aber schon artikel habe ich
ihnen die hälfte von zurückgeschickt ich
finde es einfach geil weil
ein laden geht uns die sachen kaufda
sagen meistens ja kann es eine woche
lang zurückgeben wochen wenn es nicht
ausgepackt hast und du kannst du
auspacken ich bin mit meinem hier wird
die komplette wohnung ist alles
ungenügend und trotzdem noch
zurückschickte habe es angenommen
eigentlich fast dass die länge ist wie
ein komplett dummer mensch das was ihr
von dem ich meine damen und herren ich
hoffe dadurch gefallen weil es getan hat
las roten bank
hier findet ihr jetzt mal die
eingeblendete darauf könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren werden eis weil dann habe ich
halt neues auto und hier findet ihr das
video von den dümmsten amazon artikeln
eingeblendet ist eigentlich nicht witzig
aber wenn jetzt anteilig geld und dann
kann ich mir neue artikel amazon
bestellt deswegen würde ich sagen das
war von mir ich hoffe euch hat das video
gefallen